[Music]
in a world full of crime one man is
determined to kill Batman once and for
all his name his director Joel
Schumacher action
Batman and Robin watch Academy
award-winning ladies man George Clooney
phone it in as Batman a hero capable of
performing impossible fees except for
moving his neck or body unfortunately he
is not alone in a film full of way too
many supporting characters he's bringing
even for Robin an Aggie sidekick you and
Ben will both want to punch in the face
I want a car chicks dig the car how are
we supposed to work together if you
won't trust me it's Batman and Robin not
Robin in Batman
I want to Robin sing on this guy all
right I'll go it's so low and Alfred's
British nice bad girl who talks like
Sharon clueless together they'll all
awkwardly wait for this movie to be over
witness Schumacher's creepy rubber
fetish as his camera lingers on that
crotch that bud fat boobs and male bat
nips poison ivy wants to cover the world
in plants Mr Freeze wants to cover the
world in ice they'll team up even though
their goals are completely incompatible
to make the most puns ever yeah cool
party enough monkey business allow me to
break the base let's cool it for now and
their bad puns are just the tip of the
iceberg talk about you cold shoulder so
this is where you hang out no Beauty
just the Beast no sign of the Snowman
maybe you melted no he's just
hibernating okay that when did he make
sense so if you loved Adam West's Batman
but wish it was even more can be less
fun and full of grappling hooks latching
onto things
we've got the film for you we cut our
funding there was a conflict of
ideologies there are things about me
that you wouldn't understand seven
minutes never leave the cave without it
starry real-life Bruce Wayne Christopher
Robin
the punning man cold mad the Barbarian
kindergarten iced Bob Terminator blue
all right we get it
Strom Thurmond 90s Emma Stone Tom hardly
vivica still not actually a fox and
Coolio the worst Batman ever if you
don't believe us just ask the people who
worked on it the Batman thing I wasn't
ever wholly comfortable with they felt
like we kind of rushed getting that
second one done I actually had no idea
that there was a bad girl if I
disappointed them in any way then I
really want to apologize because it
wasn't my intention
be sure to subscribe and check out our
Comic Con coverage
same bat-time same bat-channel one does
not simply walk into Mordor I hate to
disappoint you but rubber lips are
immutable charms
flubber better today we are canceling
the apocalypse Large Marge
said pee damn you Sharktopus